How's it going everyone? In this video,
we are going to talk about scalping
using the T trades fractal model. We'll
talk about how to use higher time frame
analysis, time frame alignment all the
way from bias to entry. Let's get into
the PDF. So, for scalping, we still want
to align with a higher time frame
candle. Now, generally, this is always
going to be the daily time frame, but
for scalping, we're using much lower
time frames. So, we're going to focus on
the hourly chart. So, we want to be able
to anticipate where this next hourly
candle is going to go. The easiest way
to do that is to have a candle 2 closure
on the hourly or a candle 3 closure and
be able to anticipate an expansion
candle that follows. So, here you can
see we have a fair value gap, internal
liquidity, two external liquidity, a
candle 2 closure. We have a bullish bias
for this next candle. Now using that
hourly bias we're going to find a
15-minute swing point. Now simply we are
looking for the swing point that forms
the hourly low and then looking for a
candle to closure there where we can
anticipate expansion. Now inside that
expansion candle on the 15-minute or
where we are expecting price to expand
to. Then we're going to look for a
15-minute and 1 minute fractal model. So
here we have a candle 2 closure. We have
a change in the state of delivery. Then
we can be looking for a continuation to
allow the wick of this candle three on
the 15-minute to form its wick. And then
we can be waiting for a continuation on
the 1 minute time frame to form the wick
of the higher time frame candle. And
from there look to get on side. And so
what are we actually doing here? We are
trading the body of the hourly candle
using a 15-minute and 1 minute fractal
model. So let's get into trading view
and go over a few examples of this. So
here we are in our first example. It is
important to note we're in a daily
bullish trend on gold here. And what do
we have? We have expansion into a
consolidation.
Now, a consolidation is a continuation
signature to me. So, I'd be more
interested in a sweep of the low to go
higher versus a sweep of a high to go
lower. And we also have this gap that's
overlapping that. So, if we're taking a
look at it, this is a good point of
interest for a move higher. Now, we're
on the hourly chart because we want to
have an hourly bias before we go down
and look for a 15-minute swing and a 1
minute entry. So, as we let this
continue, what do we have? We have a
candle to closure off of this low. So,
taking a look at this with context, we
have an hourly sweep here opposing the
order flow. This is where we can look
for a move higher in this next candle
and even the next candle. So, let's take
a look and see if we have a 15-minute
swing point. So, taking a look here, we
do not have a 15-minute swing point that
I am willing to trade. I could trade
this technically in candle 4, but I'm
going to wait for a valid swing point
within my model. Now, you see, we go
ahead and take the highs before we can
get on side with that. And that is okay.
It's less ideal, but what do I want to
be looking for? Are we going to form a
reversal at this high? Or are we going
to get a retracement to continue higher
or a consolidation? in which case we can
repeat the process we just went over. So
what am I going to do to do that? This
candle tells me reversal or retracement,
right? Very aggressive move back in. I
want to give it another candle. And here
you can see now we have a 15-minute
swing point and it is filling both of
these fair value gaps right here. So we
have a small wick on the hourly time
frame which supports expansion. And if
we go back to the hourly time frame,
yes, we did not close the greatest here,
but we identified that this is not a
reversal off the high. The lower time
frames or the 15-minute swing point is
forming the wick of this hourly candle.
So, when we go back to the 15-minute
time frame, we can use this as a candle
to closure that closed back inside the
previous candle's low. Well, then we can
go down to the 1 minute. And so from
here, we are going to be looking to
trade the 15-minute and 1 minute fractal
model in line with this hourly open,
low, high, close, or bullish expansion
candle. Let's go ahead and remove all
these drawings and clear it up. We have
some pretty clean highs right here. So,
let's see how we could get on side. Here
you can see we open up, we have the
confirmation, then we reach into a fair
value gap here. So, I'd be looking for
what? A continuation entry. Now, do we
get that closure over? No. Let's see if
we get a closure over on the next candle
or so. If we can get that or if we're
going to make a new low.
And we do get that closure over. So,
this is something I'd be willing to take
an entry on. Put my stop on the low and
then be looking for 2 R. Now, I'm not
too concerned about not taking profit
here, but I am willing to see how price
reacts in this area. If I do not want
that risk-to-reward, I could look for a
retest, right? And then look to get to R
to that high. It just depends on what
you want to do. Do you want to be in the
trade or are you willing to let this
trade leave you? Let's see. You can see
we get a consolidation. We trade higher.
And we do hit our two R there. So, just
to review, we're trading an hourly
expansion candle. So, you need the bias
or the narrative for this hourly candle
to expand. And then you're looking to
align a 15minute and 1 minute fractal
model with that. And that's how you're
scalping with context. then we're just
going to use protected swings, which
I've talked about in multiple other
YouTube videos, to get on side with this
move higher. Let's get into another
example. So, here we are in our next
example on YM on the hourly chart. If
you notice, we have expansion down and a
very shallow move against into a fair
value gap here. And we have some equal
lows resting below, right? This fair
value gap as well as this low right
here. So this gives us context for this
candle closure right here, this candle 2
closure to be able to trade it lower in
this candle three. So if we're
anticipating the hourly to expand lower,
what can we then do? Go down to the
15-minut time frame. Here you can see
we're on the 15minut time frame. We have
a nice expansion and this is getting
bought back up. So we want to see that
this fair value gap holds right here.
It's very small. Let's see if we get a
candle closure that aligns with that.
And we do, right? Take out this candle
with no wick. We have a candle two
closure. So now what do we have? We have
a candle two closure. So we have a
candle three on the 15-minute also
aligning with a candle three on the
hourly. So we can go down to the 1
minute time frame and see if we can get
on side with this move lower. But here
we are. Let's see if there's anything
that sets up as we let this print. We
don't want to see price trade above this
area. So, we'd want to see price trade
into this fair value gap or see if we
can get an open, high, low, close. Let's
see what happens.
And you can see price doesn't trade into
our point of interest before trading
lower. So, this is something that I
would miss here. And could I trade it
below the lows? Sure. But it's just not
something I prefer to do, right? Cuz
this is where we can get a new phase of
price. Let's see where our targets are
all the way down here. So, it is a
option. If I wanted to, I could trade
this continuation into these lows here.
But this is generally the entry I want
to see. Let's see how this works out if
we get stopped out or it works out.
You can see it takes its sweet time, but
we do finally get that move lower on the
continuation. Now, this would have been
the A+ entry if we could have gotten
something that looked a little bit like
this, where we have a candle. It digs
its wick up into there and then a
continuation lower. We didn't get that.
So then once we take out these
short-term lows, we have to look for the
phases of price. Is this a reversal? No,
that is a retracement. So then that is a
valid continuation to look for a trade
lower. And that's why it's important to
notice your higher time frame targets.
If we weren't looking for this higher
time frame target, we most likely would
have not looked for this trade as it had
already traded below the short-term
lows. But just to review, we have an
hourly swing point and then I'm looking
to trade the continuation inside that
candle 3 or inside that candle 4. To do
that, I'll go down to the 15-minute time
frame and look for a swing point. So,
you can see getting entry into that
candle 3. And this one could have even
provided another entry. As you can see,
we have another swing point in there. If
I go down to the 1 minute, do we have
another entry? Well, we possibly could
have traded this in here, right? this
continuation right here as it breaks
down and that could have been another
possibility for an entry. So let's get
into another example. So here we are in
one more example and what do we have? We
have this little consolidation range
which we had taken out the low and then
we have expanded through the high. And
once again when we're at the high of a
consolidation range and we are bullish
we want to see do we form a reversal
here or do we have a retracement or a
consolidation? A retracement or a
consolidation is a continuation
signature. So if you're bullish, you
want to see that. What do we have? We
have this gap here, right? An hourly
gap. So hourly internal to external. And
we could be looking to trade this
higher. Now opening up candle 3 on the
hourly at noon. Then we would want to be
going down to the 15minut time frame.
Now do we have a swing point going into
this? Yes. Right. We have what? This
candle two closure wasn't super great.
But then we have another candle two
closure right here. Now this alone I
would not trust as a candle 2 closure as
it is a bearish candle. But when candle
3 prints and engulfs all of these
candles right here or this candle and
the body are there. I'm then now
trusting that as long as the EQ is
respected here, we can trade this higher
because it's the open of a new hourly
candle. So we want to see open low, high
close of the hourly. And the same thing
on the 15-minute. So, we can drop down
to the 1 minute time frame. So, down
here on the 1 minute time frame, we'll
remove all of our drawings to clear it
up. And what do we have? You know, we
have a bit of a model forming in both
directions, but going into this new
higher time frame candle, you notice how
we already have a protected swing going
into the open. This means we can
anticipate that this low should hold
before the open of the new higher time
frame candle. And that makes sense
because it's below the EQ. So, I could
position at the open of the new higher
time frame candle and look for 2 R that
way. How else could we have do this?
Well, we could do it by waiting for a
continuation in that new higher time
frame candle. Let's see how both of
these work out. So, here you can see we
open up. We're reaching into this fair
value gap here and filling this one up
here as well. Do we form a continuation?
Let's see.
Right. And there you go. And see, we do
form a continuation. I was replaying it
a bit quickly, but you could use either
level here. So, either entering on this
close through with your stop there,
looking for two R, which gives
relatively the same entry, or you could
look for the retest as well. Let's see
how this works out.
And you can see there both TPS would
have hit. So, just to review, we have an
hourly candle 3 in which case we're
expecting expansion. Then we're looking
for a swing point on the lower time
frame. Here we have a candle for
continuation, right? And we have a
protected swing right at the end of
candle 3. So either of these entries
would work and you can trade that
higher. And just to see it on the
hourly, you're trading the 15-minute and
one minute swing point inside the wick
or what's forming the wick of this
higher time frame expansion candle from
internal to external on the hourly
chart. Now, in our final example here,
this is going to be an advanced version
of this where you can actually trade the
reversal candles if you want to. It's
just more complex and takes a deeper
understanding of open, high, low, close,
and wick size. So I will show this
example but for the majority of people I
would say don't really focus on this
example. So you can see here we've had
expansion down and a consolidation right
we've remained internal to this range
for quite some time by taking out the
range high we could be looking to the
range low now we're coming up on 930 so
we will go down to the 15-minut time
frame and our whole goal is to watch how
the open plays and then see if that's
supported by the hourly candle and the
15-minute candle. So, there's a few ways
to approach it. We can one let open play
out, which here it is. And you can see
we're having that 15-minute change in
the state of delivery here. Or we can go
down and look inside this, but mainly
the hourly is supporting expansion to
the downside. So, with this bearish
candle 3 closure, I could be looking
into this lower time frame. And then,
what am I looking for? A continuation.
Right here, we have a fair value gap.
So, we can go ahead and mark that out.
and a continuation right here. And then
you can see we have another fair value
gap and a new continuation right here.
So we're opening up candle 3 with a
protected swing right there. So we could
be looking for an entry on the open. I
could put my stop on that protected
swing and then looking for 2 R or the
other side of the consolidation which is
quite a bit lower. Let's see what
happens.
And there you can see we do hit 2 R. Now
the main thing I want to show here is if
we go back to right before we hit RTP
this hourly candle supports expansion
and it's supported by a 930 right it has
a small opposing run creates this
protected swing and trades away. So when
we get this 15-minute closure right this
is the reversal candle on the hourly
which is more advanced. It's harder to
trade but everything is aligned. This
supports expansion lower. This supports
expansion lower. And I'm trading a
continuation. Now, if we go back to the
15-minute time frame, you can see we can
take our target right in there or look
for these consolidation lows like so.
And that is an example of a more
advanced entry because you are trading
candle 2 here, which is a lot more
difficult. But with that, I hope you
enjoyed this video. If you did, please
consider liking and subscribing. And if
you want access to the free PDF shown
here today, please visit my website.
It's linked in the description below and
you can access all the materials there.
I'll see you guys next time. Have a good
one.